water is deadlier than wind when it
comes to hurricanes
in fact it causes 90 percent of the loss
of lives related to powerful storms
but when meteorologists talk about a
category 3 system headed their way
that classification just takes wind
speed into account
there's no single scale to indicate both
how strong
and how wet the systems are in general
we tell people
in the meteorological community to
[Music]
hide from the wind but run from the
water but if we know water can actually
cause more damage
why haven't we updated the way we
measure hurricanes let's take a look
back
the saffir-simpson scale going from 1 to
5 measures the speed of sustained winds
of a hurricane
it was developed in the 1970s to
calculate how much wind can impact
property
a storm becomes a category 1 hurricane
when winds reach
74 miles per hour this kind of speed can
damage roofs
sidings and knock large branches out of
trees major hurricanes
start at category 3 once winds increase
to 111 miles per hour
they can cause devastating destruction
to well-constructed buildings
and there's a high chance of injury or
death
category 5 hurricanes have winds over
157 miles per hour
and are the top of the scale these
systems can devastate large areas
leaving them uninhabitable for months
but again this is just from the winds it
doesn't take into consideration the
impacts of storm surge and rain
storm surge happens when winds push
water from the sea
onto the land flooding large areas it's
fast
powerful and can send 10 to 20 feet of
water several miles inland from the
coast
hurricane katrina was one of the
deadliest storms to ever hit the
mainland united states
but its 127 miles per hour winds meant
it was only classified as a category 3
when it made landfall in louisiana
the water broke the levees protecting
new orleans and within a day
about 80 percent of the city was
underwater with hurricane katrina in
2005 we really
didn't we didn't have in the collective
like public mindset you know the
difference between
a really large powerful storm and a
compact powerful storm the pictures and
the memories of katrina
aren't really about the wind damage it's
mostly about the storm surge
the levees failing in new orleans things
like that and even smaller category 1
systems like hurricane dali which
slammed south texas in 2008
can leave behind death and destruction
for the same reason
for a while the saffer simpson scale
also categorized storm surge
but it became difficult to communicate
the specific dangers of each storm to
the public
since the threats from water and wind
can be so different
so in 2017 noaa's national hurricane
center started issuing official storm
surge watches and warnings
what's different about the storm surge
warning is what's different about the
storm surge it can occur
in somewhat different locations than the
strongest wind
and at different times these advisories
are key to helping people prepare even
if they're not directly in the path of a
storm but they still leave out potential
flooding that could be caused by
rainfall
which is a whole other advisory from
noaa you need to know if your location
is going to be impacted by
storm surge or potentially fresh water
flooding
that occurs from incredible rainfall
amounts because
the time to evacuate or whatever isn't
when the water is rising into your home
or business
it's beforehand the suffer simpson
scale's historical popularity and basic
one to five format
means it's unlikely to go away anytime
soon but there are a few alternatives
out there
like the hurricane severity index owned
by storm geo a private weather
intelligence company
it uses a 50-point scale that measures
the size of a hurricane and the
intensity of its winds
each component gets 25 points to be more
precise
a size is very important because it
matters for the
aerial extent of the impact how much
time
a hurricane is going to hit you things
like storm surge
wave heights rain amounts are greater
the hsi can also help people compare
storms they might have already
experienced
to get an idea of what to expect the
index would have placed katrina's damage
potential in line with a category 5
while its intensity was only 13 out of
25 its size was a 23 out of 25
but media outlets rarely use the index
as a tool relying mostly on the saffer
simpson scale
most journalists include noaa's storm
surge advisories in their reports as
well but most of the attention around a
storm
still seems to center on the category it
falls under
atlantic hurricane season goes from june
1st to november 30th
and 2020 has been a particularly active
one with things like climate change in a
warming world
you know hurricanes are more
there's going to be more intense
hurricanes making landfall
noaa predicted 19 to 25 named storms
and as of september 21st we've already
had 23
that's already beaten last year's 18
named storms
which was also above average and even as
weather forecasting has been refined and
improved
experts say there's no substitute for
always being ready for a storm to hit
we have to make sure everybody
understands that the forecasts aren't
perfect
and sometimes the storm does something
not quite what we forecast
and you really need to be prepared most
importantly follow the advice
of your local emergency management
officials